This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We were almost done working on this week's show when news broke Thursday evening. News that required an on-air warning before our colleagues could even discuss it. And Oval Office conversation turns vulgar. And I want to acknowledge what I'm about to say could offend some people.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。周四傍晚突发新闻时，我们本周的节目几乎已经制作完成了。这条新闻在我们的同事甚至还没来得及讨论之前，就需要先做一个节目警告。椭圆办公室的对话变得粗俗。我想说明的是，我接下来要说的话可能会冒犯到一些人。
He asked why the United States would admit people from African nations, which he called shit hole countries. Trump then told lawmakers he would rather see more immigrants from Norway. The vote are coming out. I'm not a racist. I am the least racist person you have ever figured out.
他质问美国为什么要接纳来自非洲国家的人，并称这些国家是“粪坑”国家。随后，特朗普告诉议员们，他更希望看到来自挪威的移民。投票结果出来了。我不是种族主义者。我是你们所见过的最不带种族主义色彩的人。
In light of President Trump's comments, as well as ongoing debate over the program known as deferred action for childhood arrivals or DACA, we thought we'd switch gears and bring you this conversation from October 2016. As a journalist, I think this conversation is timely. As an immigrant myself, I think it's essential. Our airwaves are filled with debates about migrants, refugees, and undocumented immigrants. Who should be in the United States?
鉴于特朗普总统的言论，以及围绕被称为“童年抵美者暂缓遣返”计划（即DACA）的持续争论，我们决定转换一下思路，为您带来这段2016年10月的对话。作为一名记者，我认为这段对话很切合时宜。作为一名移民，我认为这至关重要。我们的广播节目中充满了关于移民、难民和无证移民的争论。谁应该留在美国？
Who shouldn't? And who should decide? It's an issue that seems to get to the core of who we are, who we want to be, and where we're headed as a nation. Today we're going to take a fresh look at the issue by exploring what history can teach us about the patterns and paradoxes of immigration in a nation of immigrants? My guest today is Maria Christina Garcia. She's a historian and professor of American studies at Cornell University. Maria Cristina, welcome to Hidden Brain.
谁不应该？谁来决定？这个问题似乎触及了我们是谁、我们想成为谁，以及我们作为一个国家正走向何方的核心。今天，我们将通过探讨历史能教给我们关于一个移民国家中移民的模式和悖论的知识，来对这个问题进行全新的审视。我今天的嘉宾是玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜·加西亚。她是康奈尔大学的历史学家兼美国研究教授。玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。
Thank you. So we call ourselves a nation of immigrants, and that's more than a saying, it's more than even a fact, it's a foundational story of the United States. And I want to start with this idea, many of us take genuine pride in being a country whose most famous symbol is the Statue of Liberty.
谢谢。所以我们称自己为一个移民国家，这不仅仅是一种说法，甚至不仅仅是一个事实，它是美国的一个奠基故事。我想从这个想法开始：我们许多人对作为一个以最著名的象征——自由女神像——为荣的国家而感到由衷的自豪。
That's correct. Immigrants and refugees are central to the American National Mythology to the stories that we tell about ourselves as a people. We honor this history with museums and historical markers. We commercialize it with celebrations like St. Patrick's Day and Mausincol de Mayo. But despite the centrality of immigrants and immigration to the American story, many of us have been wary of immigrants and we see this all throughout history. We have attention there, we have a contradiction. One has only to read a Benjamin Franklin, for example, to get a sense of these contradictions. In the 1750s, for example, Franklin called the German residents of Pennsylvania stupid. He complained about their inability to learn English, and he warned his readers that they
没错。移民和难民是美国国家神话的核心，也是我们作为一个人群所讲述的故事的核心。我们用博物馆和历史纪念碑来纪念这段历史。我们通过圣帕特里克节和五月五日节等庆祝活动将其商业化。但是，尽管移民和移民潮在美国故事中占据核心地位，我们许多人一直对移民保持警惕，我们在整个历史中都能看到这一点。我们存在某种紧张关系，存在一种矛盾。人们只需阅读本杰明·富兰克林的著作，就能对这些矛盾有一个直观的感受。例如，在1750年代，富兰克林称宾夕法尼亚州的德国居民为“愚蠢的人”。他抱怨他们学不会英语，并警告读者说，他们
would soon overrun, that Germans would soon overrun the American continent. And yet, it's also important to know that Benjamin Franklin published one of the first German language newspapers in the colonies. So there was that contradiction there, right? So fast forward also to the early national period. Immigration was welcome because it was important to nation building.
很快就会淹没，德国人很快就会淹没美洲大陆。然而，同样重要的是要知道，本杰明·富兰克林出版了殖民地最早的德语报纸之一。所以这里存在那种矛盾，对吧？那么，再快进到早期国家时期。移民受到欢迎，因为这对国家建设很重要。
We needed immigrants. The new nation needed immigrants to work in the mills and the factories to work in the mines, to harvest the crops, to build the infrastructure of American towns and cities. In many communities you didn't even need to be a citizen in order to vote. And yet, you know, a couple of decades later by the 1840s and 1850s, we see the emergence of the Know Nothing Party immensely hostile to German and Irish Catholic immigrants, demanding
我们需要移民。新国家需要移民在工场和工厂工作，在矿山工作，收割庄稼，建设美国城镇的基础设施。在许多社区，你甚至不需要成为公民就能投票。然而，你知道的，几十年后的1840年代和1850年代，我们看到了“一无所知党”的崛起，该党极度敌视德国和爱尔兰天主教移民，要求
federal restrictions on immigration, and trying to prevent immigrants from voting and holding public office. There are so many other examples I could give you. You mentioned the Statue of Liberty during the 1870s and 1880s, as the Statue of Liberty is going up in New York Harbor to celebrate the end of slavery. Americans are demanding at this time that the Chinese be barred from immigrating to the United States and in Congress complies in 1882 with the Chinese Exclusion Act. So we see these tensions and these contradictions all throughout American history.
对移民实行联邦限制，并试图阻止移民投票和担任公职。我还可以举出很多其他的例子。你提到了自由女神像，在1870年代和1880年代，正当自由女神像在纽约港竖起以庆祝奴隶制废除之际，美国人当时却要求禁止中国人移民美国，国会在1882年通过了《排华法案》。因此，我们在整个美国历史中都能看到这些紧张关系和矛盾。
I understand that you yourself came to the United States as a refugee and your own family, your own history of for surviving in the United States and being seen by others, and then your own family's history in terms of how you see other people coming in, or how your family sees other people coming in, reflects this broader pattern, this tension, or this paradox in how we think about immigration. Yes, you're right. My family immigrated in the 1960s. I was just a toddler. We immigrated from Cuba. We were privileged compared to other immigrants.
据我所知，你自己就是作为难民来到美国的，你自己的家庭、你们在美生存并被他人看待的历史，以及从你们如何看待其他人的角度来看你们家族的历史，或者从你们的家人如何看待其他人的角度来看，都反映了这种更广泛的模式、这种紧张关系，或者我们在思考移民问题时的这种悖论。是的，你说得对。我的家人在20世纪60年代移民。我当时还只是个幼儿。我们从古巴移民过来。与其他移民相比，我们是享有特权的。
We were privileged because we were refugees arriving during the Cold War from a communist country. And so the proverbial red carpet was rolled out for us. But just two decades later, we see another migration from Cuba during the 1980, Murray Al-Bot left. And by the 1980s, those Cubans who had arrived earlier and were more established and had managed to move up the economic ladder, and were feeling much more secure in their position, began to feel very nervous about the new arrivals who were coming in from Cuba in 1980.
我们享有特权，因为我们是在冷战期间从一个共产主义国家抵达的难民。因此，我们受到了隆重的红地毯欢迎。但仅仅二十年后，在1980年马列尔偷渡事件期间，我们看到了来自古巴的另一场移民潮。到20世纪80年代，那些更早到达、更加稳定并且已经在经济阶梯上有所上升、对自己的地位感到更加安心的古巴人，开始对1980年从古巴涌入的新移民感到非常紧张。
They wondered if these new Cubans who had grown up in a communist regime could truly understand democratic institutions, whether they could understand capitalism. And so these older Cubans, more established Cubans, wondered if the new arrivals would undermine everything that they had accomplished in South Florida and in other communities where they had settled. We see this with every immigrant group. When you look at American history, again, history can teach us a lot. For example, in the 19th century, some of the most vitriolic voices of the anti-Chinese
他们想知道这些在共产主义政权下长大、新来的古巴人是否能真正理解民主制度，是否能理解资本主义。因此，这些老一代的、更稳定的古巴人开始担心，新来的人会破坏他们在南佛罗里达州以及他们定居的其他社区所取得的一切成就。我们在每一个移民群体身上都能看到这一点。当你审视美国历史时，历史再次能教给我们很多东西。例如，在19世纪，反华运动中最尖锐的一些声音
movement were Irish immigrants and their children, who themselves had been much maligned. And now, in turn, they were directing a lot of that hostility towards newer arrivals this time from China. German Jews who had arrived in the early 19th century were also highly suspicious and worried about the Eastern European Jews who migrated at the end of the 19th century because they too feared that their status in society would be undermined by the newer arrivals. So I guess it's a very human response for those who are more established to worry about what the newer arrivals might do to undermine their hard work. So this is such a fascinating idea that people come to the United States and within a couple of decades their point of view shifts from the point of view of people who say, we really
来自于爱尔兰移民及其子女，他们自己曾饱受恶评。而现在，他们反过来将许多敌意转向了这次来自中国的新移民。在19世纪早期到达的德国犹太人，对在19世纪末期迁移而来的东欧犹太人也高度怀疑并感到担忧，因为他们同样担心自己 A 的社会地位会受到新来者的破坏。所以我想，对于那些更稳定的人来说，担心新来者可能会如何破坏他们的辛勤工作，这是一种非常人性的反应。这是一个如此迷人的想法：人们来到美国，在几十年内，他们的观点就从那些说“我们真的
want to make it in the United States to being really worried about whether the people coming after them are going to be able to make it in the United States. And we sort of see this pattern writ large in all manner of ways, you know, in the current debates that we have about immigration. I've heard people say, you know, in the current debates that we have about immigration. I've heard people say, you know, people whose families have been here for many generations. They say that, you know, when their ancestors came to America, they wanted to become Americans to leave old ways behind. And some of these people worry that more recent immigrants are less interested in assimilation.
想在美国闯出一片天地”的人，转变为真正担心后来者是否能够在美国闯出一片天地的态度。我们以各种方式在大范围内看到了这种模式，你知道的，在我们当前关于移民的争论中。我听人说过，你知道的，在我们当前关于移民的争论中。我听人说过，你知道的，那些家族在这里已经繁衍了多代的人。他们说，你知道的，当他们的祖先来到美洲时，他们希望成为美国人，将旧的生活方式抛在脑后。其中一些人担心，较近的移民对同化的兴趣较小。
But from what I'm hearing you say, that might not actually be grounded in historical reality in terms of how immigration patterns have unfolded over the years. You're so right. Many Americans today believe that the new immigrants are too culturally different, that they're coming here to take American jobs or mousse off of welfare, that they have the run politics, that they don't want to learn English, that they don't want to assimilate, that their national security threats. But these attitudes, they're not new.
但从我听到的你的话来看，就移民模式多年来的演变而言，这可能并非真正植根于历史现实中。你说的太对了。今天的许多美国人认为，新移民在文化上差异太大，他们来这里是为了抢走美国的工作岗位或靠福利生活，他们会把政治搞砸，他们不想学英语，他们不想被同化，他们是国家安全威胁。但这些态度并不新鲜。
Americans have been saying this about every immigrant group throughout American history. According to American immigration mythology, those who came, say, in the 19th century or in the early 20th century were the ideal immigrants. They learned English quickly, they wanted to be Americans, but the study of history doesn't bear that up. When you study history, it challenges those assumptions that we have about the older immigrants versus the new immigrants.
在整个美国历史中，美国人对每一个移民群体都这样说过。根据美国的移民神话，那些在19世纪或20世纪初到来的人是理想的移民。他们学英语快，他们想成为美国人，但历史研究并不支持这一点。当你研究历史时，它挑战了我们对老移民与新移民的固有假设。
So for example, let me give you a couple of examples. From the study of history, we now know that not everyone who came to the United States stayed. The two groups that had the lowest return rates were the 19th century Irish and Eastern European or Russian Jews. Every other immigrant group had return rates between 20 and 80%. We also know from the study of history that most immigrants who came to the United States did not immigrate to become American. In many cases, in most cases, immigrants came to replicate the best of the old country
所以，举个例子，让我给你举几个例子。通过历史研究，我们现在知道，并不是所有来到美国的人都留下来了。回流率最低的两个群体是19世纪的爱尔兰人和东欧或俄罗斯犹太人。其他所有移民群体的回流率都在20%到80%之间。我们从历史研究中还知道，大多数来到美国的人并不是为了成为美国人而移民的。在许多情况下，在大多数情况下，移民来到这里是为了在新的、更优惠的环境中，重现旧国家的最好部分
in more favorable circumstances in the new. As I said earlier, in many communities, you didn't even need to be a citizen in order to vote. We also know from the study of history that in the 19th century immigrants didn't learn English quickly. From the very beginning, this was a multilingual society. And it oftentimes took several generations for English to become the dominant language on Main Street. Our founding documents were all published in German to accommodate the German speaking populations.
正如我早些时候所说，在许多社区，你甚至不需要成为公民就能投票。我们从历史研究中还知道，在19世纪，移民并没有很快学会英语。从一开始，这就是一个多语言社会。英语往往需要几代人的时间才能成为主街上的主导语言。我们的建国文件全部用德语出版，以照顾讲德语的人口。
For most of the 19th century instruction in public schools across the country, from Pennsylvania to Texas to Wisconsin, populations. For most of the 19th century instruction in public schools across the country, from Pennsylvania to Texas to Wisconsin, occurred entirely in languages other than English or bilingual. And this practice was not abolished until the first decades of the 20th century. So our preoccupation today in the early 21st century with requiring linguistic and cultural conformity, that's really a recent phenomena. From the study of history, we also know that immigrants
在整个19世纪，全国各地公立学校的教学，从宾夕法尼亚到德克萨斯再到威斯康星，人口。在整个19世纪，全国各地公立学校的教学，从宾夕法尼亚到德克萨斯再到威斯康星，完全用英语以外的语言进行或使用双语。直到20世纪的前几十年，这种做法才被废除。因此，今天在21世纪初，我们对要求语言和文化顺从的关注，实际上是一个最近才出现的现象。从历史研究中我们还知道，移民
didn't think of themselves as legal or illegal. They just didn't think in those terms. During much of our history, people moved across our borders with ease. If your ship docked outside of New York City, chances were you weren't even interviewed. Congress passed the first immigration laws to control the movement of people beginning
并不认为自己是合法的还是非法的。他们根本不从这些角度思考。在我们历史的大部分时间里，人们轻松地跨越我们的边境。如果你的船停在纽约市外，你很可能连面试都没有经历过。国会通过了第一批控制人员流动移民法，始于
in the 1870s, but the mechanisms to enforce those laws were pretty few until the 20th century. Indeed, the first border patrol consisted of only a couple dozen men on horseback. So when someone says to me, my ancestor is immigrated legally. Why can't they? My first question is, when did your ancestors immigrate? Because if they immigrated in the 19th century or in the early 20th century, they simply didn't use that vocabulary. They didn't think in those terms. So clearly, much of the language around immigration has changed over time. But there are also ideas that have remained relatively constant. When we come back, I'll ask Maria Cristina about the long and tangled relationship between immigration and national security.
19世纪70年代，但在20世纪之前，执行这些法律的机制非常少。事实上，第一支边境巡逻队仅由几十名骑马的人组成。因此，当有人对我说，“我的祖先是合法移民，为什么他们不能呢？”我的第一个问题是，“你的祖先是什么时候移民的？”因为如果他们在19世纪或20世纪初移民，他们根本不使用那种词汇。他们不从这些角度思考。很明显，围绕移民的许多语言随着时间推移而改变了。但也有些观点保持了相对恒定。当我们回来时，我将询问玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜关于移民与国家安全之间长期且纠葛的关系。
Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Our debates over immigration are often framed in the context of national security, fears of terrorism. To many of us, this feels relatively new. Part of the 9-11 world we've lived in over the past 15 years. But Maria Cristina Garcia says that if we look at history, we start to see that our modern concerns are a new version of a story that's been told over and over again. Americans have been concerned about national security
请继续收听。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们对移民的争论往往是在国家安全和恐怖主义恐惧的背景下进行的。对我们许多人来说，这感觉相对较新。这是我们过去15年来生活其中的“9·11”世界的一部分。但玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜·加西亚表示，如果我们审视历史，就会开始发现，我们现代的担忧其实是一个被反复讲述的故事的新版本。美国人一直在担忧国家安全
since the 19th century. One has only to look at the political cartoons of Thomas Nast, for example, to see how concerned Americans were about Irish Catholics, for example. Thomas Nast produced these political cartoons warning Americans about all these Catholics who were coming to the United States who were under the influence of the Vatican who didn't understand democratic principles and would undermine democratic institutions.
自19世纪以来。例如，人们只需看看托马斯·纳斯特的政治漫画，就能看出美国人对爱尔兰天主教徒的担忧程度。托马斯·纳斯特创作这些政治漫画，警告美国人注意所有这些来到美国的受梵蒂冈影响、不理解民主原则并会破坏民主制度的天主教徒。
And so that's an early example of Americans concerned about national security. In the late 19th century, you see Americans expressing great concern about all the southern and Eastern Europeans who are coming in, who are anarchists and Bolsheviks and socialists who don't understand, again, don't understand American democracy, will undermine American principles, American democratic institutions. And this concern is strong enough that it forces Congress to pass a series of court alas, a barring immigration from southern and eastern Europe. We see concerns about the Chinese and other Asian groups. So we see that concern about national security throughout American history. Americans may not have used
所以这是一个美国人关注国家安全的早期例子。在19世纪后期，你会发现美国人对所有涌入的南欧和东欧人表示极大的担忧，他们是无产者、布尔什维克和社会主义者，同样不理解美国民主，会破坏美国原则和美式民主制度。这种担忧强烈到迫使国会通过了一系列法案，禁止来自南欧和东欧的移民。我们看到了对中国人和亚裔其他群体的担忧。因此，我们可以看到贯穿美国历史的国家安全担忧。美国人在19世纪可能没有使用过
the exact term national security in the 19th century, but you see those concerns all throughout the history. I want to spend a little bit of time talking about the World War II period and the experience of Japanese Americans in the United States, because it seems like that's certainly a moment where concerns about security and concerns about loyalty to the United States intersected with how we were thinking about an immigrant group. It's true during periods of national emergency, immigrants become likely scapegoats. We saw this during World War II with the internment of Japanese immigrants, but also their
“国家安全”这个确切的词，但在整个历史中你都能看到这些担忧。我想花一点时间谈谈二战时期以及美国日裔群体的经历，因为这似乎确实是一个时刻，当时对安全的担忧和对美国忠诚度的担忧与我们对一个移民群体的看法交织在了一起。确实，在国家紧急状态时期，移民很容易成为替罪羊。我们在二战期间看到了这一点，不仅关押了日本移民，还有他们的
American-born children, who, even though there was no evidence that Japanese or their children were conspiring against the US government or against American society. The government decided to err on the side of caution and round it up this population and put them in internment camps. It was one of the most shameful periods in American history. Those who were interned and their children felt the consequences of that executive decision for many, many decades afterwards. And so that's just one example.
在美国出生的孩子，尽管没有证据表明日本人或他们的孩子在密谋反对美国政府或美国社会。政府决定采取谨慎态度，将这群人围捕起来并送进拘留营。这是美国历史上最耻辱的时期之一。那些被关押的人及其后代在之后的几十年里一直感受到那个行政决定的后果。这只是一个例子。
But also during World War II, there were many opportunities that we lost to accommodate people fleeing Europe. And we lost that opportunity because we feared, again, we were concerned with national security. We feared that among the refugees, among the immigrants, would be spies and saboteurs that would undermine the United States. But those fears prevented us from accommodating many, many people who were fleeing the third Reich and needed protection, and we lost that opportunity to help them. When you look at the experience of Jewish immigrants and refugees around the time of World War II, around the 1930s, 1940s,
但在二战期间，我们也失去了许多接纳逃离欧洲的人的机会。我们之所以失去这个机会，是因为我们害怕，再一次，我们担心国家安全。我们担心在难民和移民中会有会破坏美国的间谍和破坏分子。但这些恐惧使我们无法接纳许多许多逃离第三帝国并需要保护的人，我们失去了帮助他们的机会。当你回顾二战前后（大约20世纪30年代、40年代）犹太移民和难民的经历时，
paint me a picture of what happened. The popular narrative is that there are many European Jews who did make it to the United States, many of whom were involved in the scientific research that had helped the United States eventually win World War II. But was that sort of a general experience? Did the United States was the United States generally welcoming to Jewish refugees from Europe in the middle of the 20th century? No, we weren't actually. Many historians feel that our policies were highly
请给我描绘一下当时的情况。普遍的说法是，有许多欧洲犹太人确实设法来到了美国，其中许多人参与了帮助美国最终赢得二战的科学研究。但这是一种普遍的经历吗？在20世纪中叶，美国普遍欢迎来自欧洲的犹太难民吗？不，事实上我们没有。许多历史学家认为我们的政策非常
anti-Semitic during this period. We lost many opportunities to allow Jewish refugees to come to the United States. The most classic example is the SSA in Louis. Ship carrying over 900 passengers who were fleeing Europe. And when they arrived off the American coast, the people on the ship were prevented from coming to the United States. The ship was turned away. And eventually, you know, the ship traveled to many different countries.
在这段时期内排犹。我们错失了许多允许犹太难民来到美国的机会。最典型的例子就是圣路易斯号。这艘船载着900多名逃离欧洲的乘客。当他们到达美国海岸附近时，船上的人被阻止进入美国。这艘船被赶走了。最终，你知道的，这艘船去了许多不同的国家。
They were also denied the opportunity to land. And eventually the ship was forced to return to Europe. And many of the people who were traveling on the SSC, Lewis eventually were caught and sent to camps, to the death camps. So when we look at the broad sweep of history here, we sort of see this pattern repeatedly occurring where groups arrive and within a few decades or a couple of generations of being here, they have concerns about newcomers entering their neighborhoods.
他们登陆的机会也被剥夺了。最终，这艘船被迫返回欧洲。许多乘坐圣路易斯号旅行的人最终被捕并被送往集中营、死亡集中营。因此，当我们纵观这段宏大的历史时，我们会发现这种模式反复出现：群体抵达后，在来到这里的短短几十年或几代人内，他们又开始对进入其社区的新来者产生担忧。
And in some ways, we seem to have a positive view of immigration and immigrants when they were long ago and far away. But less so when they're here now, when the family that arrived last year that lives next door. And I'm wondering if you have insight into why this happens? Why is it that groups that themselves may have faced challenges as immigrants? How is it that within a couple of decades or maybe a couple of generations, they are turning around and having the same concerns that were expressed about them not so long ago?
在某种程度上，当移民在很久以前、遥远的地方时，我们似乎对移民和移民抱有积极的看法。但当他们就在这里、现在，当去年到达并住在隔壁的家庭出现时，这种看法就不那么积极了。我想知道你是否对为什么会发生这种事有什么见解？为什么那些自己作为移民时可能面临挑战的群体，在短短几十年或几代人之内，就会回过头来产生不久前别人对他们表达过的同样的担忧？
Well that seems to be the pattern. I guess you could say that part of Americanization is to adopt the values and the perspectives of the society that surrounds you. And it also becomes a defense mechanism. It becomes a way of proving your membership in the society to adopt those values and to reflect those values out, to demonstrate that you are a member of the in-group and not the out-group. You recently wrote an essay about the current debates over immigration, in which you said, generations from now, students in U.S. history classes, many of them, the children of immigrants arriving today, will read what our political candidates, editorialists, bloggers, and talking heads had to say about their ancestors, and shudder. What did you mean by that?
嗯，这似乎就是规律。我想你可以说，美国化的一部分就是采纳包围你的社会的价值观和视角。这也成了一种防御机制。采纳这些价值观并将其反射出去，以此来证明你是内群体而不是外群体的一员，这成了证明你在社会中成员身份的一种方式。你最近写了一篇关于当前移民辩论的文章，其中提到，几代人之后，美国历史课堂上的学生——其中许多人是今天到达的移民的儿童——会读到我们的政治候选人、社论作者、博主和名嘴对他们的祖先所说的话，然后感到不寒而栗。你这话是什么意思？
When I teach courses in immigration history and we read the editorials and the newspaper articles and the newspaper articles and the broadsides that were published in the 19th and in the early 20th century. My students often shake their heads and wonder how Americans could have ever had those feelings or their thoughts or perspectives, they laugh nervously. But then when we compare those editorials and newspaper articles and broadsides to some of the editorials and blogs and newspaper articles today, they see the continuities. And so I suspect that 20 years from now, 30 years from now, I suspect that my students reading the thoughts, the articles of today, will also find them ridiculous, will also shudder, will also wonder why Americans felt the way they did.
当我教移民史课程时，我们阅读19世纪和20世纪初出版的社论、报纸文章和传单。我的学生经常摇头，想知道美国人怎么会有那种感觉、想法或视角，他们会紧张地笑。但随后我们将这些社论、报纸文章和传单与当今的一些社论、博客和报纸文章进行比较时，他们看到了连贯性。因此我猜想，20年、30年后，我的学生在阅读今天的思想和文章时，也会觉得它们荒谬可笑，也会不寒而栗，也会纳闷为什么美国人会有那样的感受。
But I hope not. There's this part of me that hopes that we will do better, that we will be better. That was historian Maria Christina Garcia. She's a professor of American studies at Cornell University. Hidden Brain is produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman, Raina Cohen, René Clair and Path Shah. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle.
但我希望不会。我内心深处有一种愿望，希望我们能做得更好，变得更好。刚才那是康奈尔大学美国研究教授玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜·加西亚。Hidden Brain由珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼、雷娜·科恩、勒内·克莱尔和帕思·沙制作。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。
This week our unsung hero is Stuart Harding. Stuart's one of NPR's lawyers, he does many things for us, from working late on a Friday to draft the rules for a t-shirt giveaway to writing the contracts for actors who will appear in an upcoming episode of the show. Thank you Stuart for all that you do for us and all that you do for everyone at NPR. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本周我们的无名英雄是斯图尔特·哈丁。斯图尔特是NPR的律师之一，他为我们做了很多事情，从周五加班起草T恤赠品规则，到为将要出现在该节目即将播出的一集中的演员撰写合同。谢谢你，斯图尔特，感谢你为我们所做的一切，以及你为NPR的每个人所做的一切。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。该剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。